No estoy realmente segura de querer ver
un redoblante a eso de las 9 de la mañana. (risas)
Pero de todos modos, es increíble ver un teatro tan lleno,
y realmente debo agradecerle a Herbie Hancock
y sus colegas por esta gran presentación.
Una de las cosas interesantes,
por supuesto, es la combinación de esa mano directa en el instrumento,
la tecnología y, por supuesto, lo que dijo acerca de escuchar a nuestros jóvenes.
Por supuesto, mi trabajo se trata de escuchar,
y mi objetivo, en realidad, es enseñarle al mundo a escuchar.
Ese es mi único objetivo verdadero en la vida.
Y suena bastante simple, pero en realidad es un trabajo muy, muy grande.
Porque ustedes saben, cuando se mira una pieza musical -por ejemplo,
si abro mi pequeño bolso- tenemos aquí, espero,
una pieza de música que está llena de pequeños puntos negros en la página.
Y saben, la abrimos y leo la música.
Por lo tanto técnicamente yo puedo leer esto.
Voy a seguir las instrucciones: las indicaciones de tempo, las dinámicas.
Voy a hacer exactamente lo que me dice.
Y así, como el tiempo es corto,
tocaré literalmente las primeras dos líneas más o menos. Es muy sencillo.
No hay nada demasiado difícil en la pieza.
Pero aquí me dice que la pieza de música es muy rápida.
Me dice en qué parte del redoblante tocar.
Me dice qué parte de las baquetas debo usar.
Y me dice la dinámica.
Y me dice también que el redoblante no tiene bordona.
Con bordona, sin bordona.
Por lo tanto, si yo traduzco esta pieza de música, tendremos esta idea.
Y así sucesivamente. Mi carrera probablemente duraría unos cinco años (risas).
Sin embargo, lo que tengo que hacer como músico es hacer todo lo que no está en la partitura.
Todo lo que no hay tiempo de aprender de un maestro,
o incluso de hablar con un maestro.
Pero son justamente las cosas que uno nota cuando no está con el instrumento
las que de hecho se vuelven tan interesantes que uno desea explorarlas
a través de esta pequeña, pequeña superficie de redoblante.
Bien: experimentamos la traducción. Ahora experimentaremos la interpretación.
Ahora mi carrera podría durar un poco más! (risas)
Pero en cierto modo, saben, es lo mismo si miro y veo
una resplandeciente joven usando una blusa rosa.
Veo que está apretando un oso de peluche, etc, etc.
Así obtengo una idea básica de cómo puede ser, de qué cosas posiblemente le gusten,
de cuál sea quizás su profesión, etcétera, etcétera.
Sin embargo esta es sólo la idea inicial que yo tendría, que todos tenemos
cuando de hecho miramos. Y tratamos de interpretarla,
pero en realidad es tan increíblemente superficial.
De la misma manera miro la partitura, tengo una idea básica,
me pregunto qué es lo que podría resultarme técnicamente difícil, o qué es lo que quiero hacer.
Sólo la sensación básica.
Sin embargo, esto simplemente no es suficiente.
Y creo que lo dijo Herbie - por favor, escuchen, escuchen.
Tenemos que escucharnos a nosotros mismos, en primer lugar.
Si yo toco, por ejemplo, sosteniendo la baqueta - en caso de que, literalmente, no me suelte de ella –
voy a experimentar una gran cantidad de sacudidas subiendo a través del brazo.
Y uno se siente - créanlo o no -
bastante desconectada del instrumento y de la baqueta,
a pesar de que en realidad estoy sujetándola muy firmemente.
Sujetándola fuerte, me siento extrañamente más separada.
Si yo simplemente libero mi mano, mi brazo, y le permito ser más un sistema de soporte,
repentinamente tengo más dinámica con menos esfuerzo. Mucho más.
Y me siento, por fin, que soy una con la baqueta y una con el redoblante.
Y estoy haciendo mucho, mucho menos.
Por lo tanto, de la misma manera que necesito tiempo con este instrumento,
necesito tiempo con las personas para interpretarlas.
No sólo traducirlas, sino interpretarlas.
Si, por ejemplo, toco tan sólo unos compases de una pieza de música
en la cual me considero un técnico,
o sea, alguien que es básicamente un ejecutante de percusión ...
y así sucesivamente. Si me considero un músico ...
y así sucesivamente. Hay una pequeña diferencia ahí (risas)
que vale la pena pensar. (aplausos)
Y recuerdo cuando tenía 12 años
y comencé a tocar timbales y percusión, y mi profesor dijo:
"Bueno, ¿cómo vamos a hacer esto? Ya sabes, la música es acerca de escuchar."
“Sí, estoy de acuerdo con eso. Así que, ¿cuál es el problema?"
Y él me dijo: "Bueno, ¿cómo vas a escuchar esto? ¿Cómo vas a escuchar aquello?"
Y yo dije, "Bueno, ¿cómo lo escucha usted?"
Él dijo: “Bueno, me parece que lo escucho por aquí”
Y yo dije, "Bueno, me parece que yo también, pero además lo escucho a través de mis manos,
a través de mis brazos, pómulos, mi cuero cabelludo, mi panza, mi pecho, las piernas y demás.”
Y así empezábamos cada lección afinando los tambores
-en particular, los timbales -
a un intervalo pequeño, algo así como…
a esa diferencia. Luego gradualmente … y gradualmente...
y es increíble que cuando abres tu cuerpo
y tu mano para permitir el paso de la vibración,
de hecho la pequeña, pequeñísima diferencia …
se puede sentir con sólo la más pequeña parte de tu dedo, ahí.
Y así que lo que hacíamos era que yo ponía mis manos en la pared
de la sala de música, y juntos "escuchábamos" los sonidos de los instrumentos,
y realmente tratábamos de conectarnos con esos sonidos
de manera mucho más amplia que simplemente dependiendo del oído.
Porque por supuesto, el oído está sujeto a todo tipo de cosas.
La habitación en la que estamos, la amplificación, la calidad del instrumento,
el tipo de baquetas, etcétera, etcétera.
Son todos diferentes.
Misma cantidad de peso, pero con diferentes “colores de sonidos”.
Y eso es básicamente lo que somos. Somos seres humanos,
pero todos tenemos nuestro propio pequeño “color de sonido”, por así decirlo,
que conforman estas extraordinarias personalidades,
caracteres, intereses y demás.
Cuando crecí, audicioné para ingresar a la Royal Academy of Music en Londres,
y me dijeron: "Bueno, no, no te aceptaremos porque no tenemos idea,
de cuál puede ser el futuro de un llamado músico 'sordo'.”
Y yo simplemente no podía aceptar eso.
Así que les dije: "Bueno, miren, si se niegan,
si me rechazan por estas razones,
--en contraposición a la capacidad de interpretar, de comprender y amar
el arte de crear sonidos--
entonces tenemos que analizar muy, muy profundamente a quiénes sí aceptan.”
Y como resultado, -una vez superado este pequeño obstáculo y teniendo una segunda audición--
me aceptaron. Y no sólo eso;
lo que había sucedido cambió completamente el rol
de las instituciones de música en todo el Reino Unido.
Bajo ninguna circunstancia rechazarían ninguna solicitud de ingreso basándose
en que alguien no tuviera brazos, o piernas;
ellos podrían tal vez tocar un instrumento de viento si se colocase sobre un soporte.
Ninguna circunstancia se utilizaría para rechazar ninguna solicitud de ingreso.
Y cada solicitud debería ser escuchada, experimentada y luego,
sobre la base de la habilidad musical, la persona podría entrar o no.
Así pues, esto a su vez significó que llegara un muy interesante
grupo de estudiantes a estas diversas instituciones de música.
Y tengo que decir, muchos de ellos están ahora
en orquestas profesionales en todo el mundo.
Lo interesante de esto también es, aunque -
(aplausos) -
es sencillamente que la gente no sólo se vincula con el sonido
--básicamente todos nosotros-- sino que sabemos que la música es realmente nuestra medicina diaria.
Digo música, pero en realidad me refiero al sonido.
Porque, ¿saben?, he experimentado algunas cosas extraordinarias
como músico: uno puede tener un muchacho de 15 años de edad,
que tiene que enfrentar enormes desafíos,
que quizas no pueda controlar sus movimientos,
que tal vez sea sordo , o sea ciego, etcétera, etcétera.
De repente, si ese joven se sienta cerca de este instrumento,
y incluso si se acuesta debajo de la marimba,
y le tocas algo increíblemente similar al órgano,
–no tengo las baquetas adecuadas-
pero algo como esto. Permítanme cambiar.
Algo que es súmamente simple...
pero él experimentaría algo que yo no experimentaría,
porque yo estoy encima del sonido.
A mí me llega el sonido de este lado.
A él le llegaría a través de los resonadores.
Si no hubiera resonadores aquí, tendríamos...
así que él tendría una plenitud de sonido que aquellos en las primeras filas
no experimentarían; aquellos de ustedes en las filas de atrás tampoco.
Cada uno de nosotros, dependiendo de donde está sentado,
experimentará este sonido de forma bastante diferente.
Y, por supuesto, siendo participante de este sonido,
y esto es partiendo de la idea de qué tipo de sonido que quiero producir -
por ejemplo, este sonido.
¿Pueden oír algo?
Exactamente. Porque ni siquiera estoy tocando.
Pero, sin embargo, tenemos la sensación de que algo pasa.
De la misma manera que cuando veo los árboles moverse,
entonces me imagino al árbol haciendo un sonido susurrante.
¿Ven lo que quiero decir?
Cualquiera cosa que el ojo mire, entonces hay siempre un sonido.
Así que siempre, siempre hay un enorme
- quiero decir - un caleidoscopio de cosas de donde extraer.
Así que todas mis actuaciones se basan en su totalidad en lo que yo vivencio,
y no en el aprendizaje de una pieza musical, o la incorporación de la interpretación de alguien más,
o en la compra de todos los CDs posibles de esa pieza musical y demás.
Porque eso no me daría suficiente material tan crudo y tan básico,
con el que yo pudiera experimentar el recorrido completo.
Por lo tanto, puede ser que, en algunas salas, esta dinámica pueda funcionar bien.
Es posible que en otras salas, simplemente no se pueda experimentar
para nada y entonces mi nivel de suavidad,
de tocar sutilmente deba ser...
¿Ven lo que quiero decir? Así que, debido a esta explosión en el acceso al sonido,
especialmente a través de la comunidad de sordos,
esto no sólo ha afectado la forma en que las instituciones de música
y las escuelas para sordos tratan el sonido. Y no sólo como un medio de terapia,
aunque, por supuesto, al ser un participante de la música,
definitivamente también es el caso.
Pero ha significado que los técnicos en acústica hayan tenido que meditar sobre los tipos de salas
que arman. Hay muy pocas salas en este mundo
que tengan realmente muy buena acústica,
me atrevería a decir. Me refiero a donde se pueda hacer absolutamente cualquier cosa que uno imagine.
Desde el más pequeño, más suave, suavísimo sonido a algo que sea tan amplio,
tan grande, tan increíble! Siempre hay algo -
puede sonar bien hasta ahí, puede no ser tan bueno allí.
Pueden ser genial ahí, pero terrible allá..
Tal vez terrible allá, pero no demasiado malo allí, etcétera, etcétera.
Por lo tanto encontrar una sala de hecho es increíble,
una en la que se pueda tocar exactamente lo que uno se imagina,
sin que sea "estéticamente mejorada".
Por lo tanto, los técnicos en acústica están en conversaciónes con las personas
que tienen problemas auditivos y que son participantes del sonido.
Y esto es muy interesante.
No puedo darles ningún detalle en lo que respecta a lo que está sucediendo
con esas salas, pero es el hecho que estén acudiendo a un grupo de personas
de las que por tantos años hemos estado diciendo:
“Bueno, ¿cómo diablos pueden experimentar la música? Tú sabes, son sordos.”
Nosotros simplemente hacemos así y nos imaginamos que la sordera es eso.
O hacemos así y nos imaginamos que la ceguera es esto.
Si vemos a alguien en una silla de ruedas, suponemos que no puede caminar.
Es posible que pueda caminar tres, cuatro, cinco pasos. Ésto, para ellos, significa que pueden caminar.
En el plazo de un año, podrían ser dos pasos más.
En otro año, tres pasos más.
Estos son aspectos muy importantes para reflexionar.
Así que cuando nos escuchemos los unos a los otros,
es increíblemente importante para nosotros poner realmente a prueba nuestra capacidad de escucha.
Usar realmente nuestros cuerpos como una cámara de resonancia. Detener el juzgamiento.
Para mí, como música que trata con un 99 % de música nueva,
es muy fácil decir: "Oh sí, me gusta esta pieza."
"Oh, no, no me gusta esta pieza.” Y así sucesivamente.
Y simplemente descubrí que tengo que darles tiempo real a esas piezas de música.
Tal vez la química no sea la correcta entre esa determinada pieza musical y yo.
Pero eso no significa que tengo derecho a decir que es una mala pieza musical.
Y ¿saben?, una de las grandes cosas acerca de ser un músico
es que es tan increíblemente fluido.
Así que no hay reglas, no hay correcto, no hay incorrecto, ni de este modo, o de ese modo.
Si les pidiera que aplaudieran -tal vez pueda hacer esto.
Si les digo: "por favor aplaudan y creen el sonido de un trueno.”
Estoy suponiendo que todos hemos experimentado el trueno.
Ahora bien, no me refiero tan sólo al sonido,
me refiero a realmente escuchar ese trueno dentro de ustedes.
Y que por favor tratende crear eso a través de su aplauso. Intenten. Sólo inténtenlo, por favor.
(aplausos)
Muy bien! Nieve. Nieve. ¿Alguna vez han escuchado la nieve?
Audiencia: No.
Evelyn Glennie: Entonces bien, dejen de aplaudir. (risas) Intenten de nuevo.
Inténtelo de nuevo. Nieve.
Ven, está despierto.
Lluvia. No está mal, no está mal.
¿Saben? Lo interesante aquí, sin embargo, es que le pedí a un grupo de niños
no hace mucho tiempo atrás exactamente lo mismo.
Ahora - gran imaginación, muchas gracias.
Sin embargo, ninguno de ustedes salió de sus asientos para pensar,
"¡Bien! ¿Cómo puedo aplaudir? OK, tal vez ...
tal vez pueda usar mis joyas para crear más sonidos.
Tal vez pueda utilizar las otras partes de mi cuerpo para crear sonidos extra."
Ni uno sólo de ustedes pensó en aplaudir de una forma ligeramente diferente
que no fuera sentado ahí en sus asientos y utilizando las dos manos.
De la misma forma que cuando escuchamos música,
suponemos que todo está ingresando por aquí.
Así es como vivenciamos la música. Por supuesto que no lo es.
Vivenciamos el trueno, trueno, trueno. Piensen, piensen, piensen.
Escuchen, escuchen, escuchen. Ahora, ¿qué podemos hacer con truenos?
Recuerdo a mi maestro. Cuando empecé, mi primera lección,
yo estaba preparada con mis baquetas, lista para comenzar.
Y no me dijo: "OK, Evelyn, por favor. Pies ligeramente separados,
los brazos más o menos en ángulo de 90 grados, baquetas más o menos en forma de "V",
mantén esta cantidad de espacio aquí, etc.
Por favor, mantén tu espalda recta, etc etc etc."
Yo probablemente hubiese terminado completamente rígida, congelada,
y no hubiese sido capaz de golpear el redoblante,
porque hubiese estado pensando en muchas otras cosas. Pero él me dijo:
"Evelyn, llévate este redoblante por siete días y te veré la próxima semana."
¡Cielos! ¿Qué iba a hacer? Ya no necesitaba las baquetas,
no me estaba permitido tener baquetas.
Básicamente tenía que mirar este redoblante en particular,
ver cómo estaba hecho, que hacían esas pequeñas lengüetas, que hacían las bordonas.
Darlo vuelta de arriba abajo, experimentado con el casco, experimentado con su parche.
Experimentado con mi cuerpo, experimentando con joyas,
experimentando con todo tipo de cosas.
Y, por supuesto, regrese con todo tipo de moretones y cosas por el estilo (risas)
pero, no obstante, fue una experiencia tan increible!
porque: ¿dónde diablos va uno a experimentar eso en una pieza de música?
¿Dónde diablos va uno a experimentar eso en un libro de estudio?
Por lo tanto, nunca, nunca lidiamos con libros de estudio reales.
Así por ejemplo, una de las cosas que aprendemos
cuando estamos lidiando con ser un ejecutante de percusión, en contraposición a ser un músico,
es básicamente una seguidilla de golpes simples y precisos de redoble.
Como eso. Y luego lo hacemos un poco más rápido y un poco más rápido y un poco más rápido.
Y así sucesivamente. ¿Qué es lo que requiere esta pieza?
Un redoble de golpes simples. Entonces, ¿por qué no puedo hacerlo durante el aprendizaje de una pieza musical?
Y eso es exactamente lo que él hizo.
Y curiosamente, cuando crecí, cuando me convertí en una estudiante de tiempo completo
en lo que se llama "una institución de música", todo eso fue descartado.
Teníamos que estudiar de los libros de estudio.
Y constantemente, la pregunta, bueno, ¿por qué? ¿Por qué? ¿Con qué está relacionado esto?
Necesito tocar una pieza de música. "Oh, bueno, ¡esto ayudará tu control!"
Bueno, ¿cómo? ¿Por qué tengo que aprender esto? Necesito vincularlo con una pieza de música.
¿Saben? Necesito decir algo.
¿Por qué estoy practicando paradiddles?
¿Es sólo, literalmente, para el control, para el control de la mano y la baqueta? ¿Por qué estoy haciendo esto?
Tengo que tener una razón,
y la razón debe ser: decir algo a través de la música.
Y diciendo algo a través de la música, que básicamente es sonido,
uno puede transmitirle todo tipo de cosas a todo tipo de personas.
Pero no quiero responsabilizarme de su equipaje emocional.
Eso depende de ustedes cuando ustedes ingresan a una sala.
Porque eso determina qué y cómo escuchamos ciertas cosas.
Me puedo sentir triste, o feliz, o exaltada, o enojada cuando toco
ciertas piezas de música, pero no estoy necesariamente
queriendo que ustedes sientan exactamente lo mismo.
Así que por favor, la próxima vez que vayan a un concierto,
sólo permitan a su cuerpo abrirse, permitan a su cuerpo ser la cámara de resonancia.
Sean conscientes que ustedes no van a experimentar lo mismo que el intérprete.
El artista está en la peor posición posible para el sonido real:
está escuchando el contacto de la baqueta con el redoblante,
o del mazo en el golpe a la madera, o del arco en la cuerda, etc.
O la respiración que está creando el sonido en los vientos y los metales.
Están experimentando la crudeza ahí.
Sin embargo están experimentando algo tan increíblemente puro,
que es anterior al sonido que efectivamente está sucediendo.
Por favor, tomen nota de la vida del sonido después de que golpe inicial,
o que la respiración, han sido dados. Sólo experimenten el viaje completo de ese sonido
del mismo modo que me hubiese gustado experimentar el recorrido completo
de esta particular conferencia, en lugar de llegar justo anoche.
Espero que podamos compartir una o dos cosas en el transcurso del día.
Muchas gracias por invitarme!
(aplausos)